Hello, how are you?
>> I'm good, how are you? Good, good, good.
So,
you you
should I answer the question on the on
the screen? Yes, please. Okay. Bismillah
So,
the Bible So, you claim the Bible is the
authority over Quran. You just have to
take a sura 5 verse 48.
And then and you can read it. It's very
simple. Yeah, it says that the that the
Quran is a confirmation of the previous
scripture and a guardian over it. Um No,
I'll read it. I'll read it.
>> I just I just did it. I just quoted it.
>> No, no, no. You have I can read from uh
from computer. I don't I just did
>> Just for me sure. I just quoted it for
you.
>> No, it doesn't matter what it says. I
just quoted it for you, Younis. It says
it's a muhaimin ali. Yeah, muhaimin No,
it means the
uh it
dominates. No, the word muhaimin the
word muhaimin literally means guardian,
brother. That's literally what it means
in Arabic.
>> How do you know that? Wait, I just
Just just make sure. We have revealed to
you oh prophet this book with the truth
as a confirmation of previous scriptures
and as a supreme authority over them.
That's a lie.
>> Supreme authority.
>> say supreme authority. The English
translation got it wrong. That's not
what muhaimin means. What? Look, so I
have the I have the I have the Arabic
right here, word-for-word breakdown of
the verse.
While muhaimin and a guardian, that's
what it means.
>> No, you Means guardian, brother. Not
supreme authority, not dominant.
>> What do you mean by guardian? It guards
them. It points back to them. It tells
the people to go back to those
scriptures and stop evading them and
stop
denying them. Well, in my in my
translation it says uh I know what it
says in your translation. Your
translation is false according to the
Arabic. So, how how do you how how do
you know like uh the the meaning of
Arabic?
Because I
Cuz I just showed you a corpus, an
Arabic corpus. The scholars break down
the Arabic word-for-word and so I just
showed you what what it means in the
corpus. So, the the Quran doesn't um
What what you see confirm all
like the stories of like the like the
the the Bible because the Bible is is
written
by a
by a by men. And the The Quran was
written by men.
>> [clears throat]
>> Was the Quran written by men? No, no,
no. The Injil is a revelation from
Allah. Was the Quran written by men? No,
it's not written by men. Who wrote the
Quran? It was revealed.
>> I knew you were going to say that cuz
you guys are the same bot. I didn't ask
you if it was revealed. I asked you who
wrote it. Who wrote the Quran? Like
describes So, men wrote it? The Quran
had scribes? For the Mus'haf, but the
the revelation came like across like
multiple forms. Same. Same Same with the
Torah and Gospel. Men wrote it. Men
wrote the Torah and Gospel, but the
revelation came from God in various
ways. But can I answer sura 10:94? I can
answer that for you. Are you sure you
can? Yeah, I can. You positive? You sure
you ready, man? Bismillah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. So, first you have to take
>> That's how I know that you're not ready,
man. You're invoking the wrong name.
You're supposed to say bism Yeshua.
Bism Yeshua in the name of Jesus the
Lord. Al Rabb. No, no, no. I'm converted
to Islam. I'm Chinese. Yeah, I I can see
that and you're you've been converted to
a a delusion. Jesus is calling you to to
the truth. So, first Bism Yeshua Al
Rabb. Bism Yeshua Al Rabb. That's what
you should say. In the name of Jesus the
Lord. No, no, it's okay.
So, first you have to take
sura 10 verse 2. You have to read it.
Then you have to read
uh sura
21 verse 7 and sura 10 verse 1 Did you
say Did you say what? 21 verse 7? Yeah,
because it's it talks It says, "And we
sent none before you but men to whom we
made revelation. Ask the people of the
remembrance. Ask the people of the
reminder if you do not know." So, what
does Allah What does What does Allah
What does Allah tell them to do if they
don't know what the Quran is saying?
Because sura sura 10 verse 2 Can we read
sura 10 verse 2? I I I I went to 21:7.
You mentioned 21:7. Okay, but it
connects sura 10 verse 2. Okay, but
let's break this down really quick.
What does Allah tell them to do in verse
in 21 verse 7 if they don't know about
what Allah himself is saying in the
Quran? What does he tell them to do? Ask
the people of the reminder, right? Yes,
because because they were astonished
that it was a man. Who are they? Who are
Who are they? Who are the people of the
reminder? It's the Jews and the the
Christians. Very good. And the reminder
is the scripture they have, right? And
there's Slow down.
And the scripture
is the reminder that they have, right?
That's why they're called the people of
the reminder, meaning their scripture,
right? The Torah and Gospel? Yeah. Yeah.
So, the Quran says again, "If you do not
know about what Allah's talking about,
then go ask those who are the people of
the reminder, the Jews and Christians."
Because they have prophets too.
No, because they have prophets. Right.
So, you coming to us
would verify what Allah is saying in the
Quran, right?
>> Because you you guys also have like
prophets who receive revelations.
>> Good. So, answer this. This should be
easy. So, coming to us and asking us in
light of our scripture
would verify what Allah is saying in the
Quran, right? It's it's about like why
why why God was
You can drop me. You don't You won't let
me speak. Yeah, you're out of here.
You're not ready. I'm ready. You're not,
bro. You're not
Read sura 10 verse 2 then I go.
>> You you're you're on this bot script.
You you're incapable of engaging as a
free human being. And I'm a human being.
And I'm a human being. Brother, you're
not ready. You do not belong here. Take
care of yourself. Take care. I'll
convert to Islam. Hamza, you're on
stage, man. Yeah, yeah. Okay, so even
though the Muslim with more knowledge
than me like Muslim Lantern, for
example, couldn't convince you that
basically your argument that you are
using is not talking about exact details
and is not talking about confirming the
Quran. It's just basically talking about
>> this conversation with Muslim Lantern,
brother. Yeah, I saw it and even though
with all those arguments, he couldn't
convince you. I I there is nothing I can
say that I'm just saying you're
I think you have me confused with
somebody else, maybe another black
apologist cuz we all look alike and
sound alike. But I never had a
conversation It might be Ali Dawah that
you are talking You're not You're not
listening.
I never had a conversation with Muslim
Lantern on the Islamic dilemma. I would
love to, but I never had that
conversation. Maybe another black guy
did it. Maybe it was Ali Dawah. Yeah,
maybe Ali Dawah had a conversation with
Muslim Lantern on the Islamic dilemma.
You got me confused with Ali Dawah.
>> Okay, it doesn't matter. The reason why
I joined is to tell people
to go to ChatGPT and ask the same
questions you are asking Muslims. Why
would I do that? I'm already debating
>> they listen to you since they are not
Muslim? Why would you talk about Quran?
I'm already I'm already debating bots.
Why would I go to another bot and debate
a bot? I'm already debating bots. I've
been debating bots all day. Yeah, but
what is your source of information about
Quran? The Quran. Okay, and do you have
it in physical form? Okay. Okay, I mean
and do you tell people when they when
you tell them to go and check specific
items for where do you tell them to go?
Where do you tell people to go to check
information? Yeah, good job. You proved
your point that you have Quran. You
should read it as well. I got many
Qurans. I got many different Qurans.
Yeah, they are not different. They are.
They are different. Can you Can you Can
you answer me the question when you tell
people to go and check? These are three
different Qurans that I have, man.
Different Arabic
>> even listening to me? Sorry, what you
said? When you tell people to go and
check some information, where do you
tell them to go? What What information?
Any information related to Quran or
whatever. Related to Quran or what?
>> Related to Quran or Bible or whatever
you're talking about. Where do you tell
them to go and check that information?
Oh, um so if somebody's asking me about
the Quran, I'll tell them to go to a
Christian who's filled with the Holy
Spirit, who's read the Quran, and go to
them and they'll go with go through the
Quran with them. If it's about the
Bible, I'll tell them to go to a
Christian who's filled with the Holy
Spirit and go over the Bible with them.
Yeah, but I'm pretty sure that you said
multiple times go to the quran.com, for
example. Did you? No. You didn't You are
sure that with previous guys you both
didn't check on the on the translations?
No. One of them had
One of them had quran.com up. I didn't
have a problem with that, but I didn't
say, "Hey, go there."
>> I think I think you did because you
literally gave another explanation of
Arabic translation even though he
understands Arabic and you don't.
>> I'm using I'm using quranx.com.
Okay, it doesn't matter. The The main
point is that uh any source information
we can find on internet depending who
posted it and whatever. And when you use
ChatGPT, yeah, I'm just I just wanted to
tell people to go and ask ChatGPT the
same question you are asking Muslims.
It's funny cuz a a Christian did that. A
a Christian went um cuz they got tired
of getting kicked off of Muslim panels
after destroying them when it comes to
the Islamic dilemma.
And I think it was
Somebody said it earlier either today in
this live or yesterday's live in the
chat. They said that they went and they
debated ChatGPT on the Islamic dilemma
and even ChatGPT couldn't refute them.
They just kept being a bot like the
normal Muslims are and saying, "Bible's
corrupted. Bible's corrupted. Bible's
corrupted."
>> Yeah.
Can you Can you share the screen and ask
him the exact exact question that you're
asking
>> No, why would I do that? I'm I'm talking
to you. I'm already talking to a bot.
Why do I want to I'm not going to go to
another bot. No, I'm already talking to
a bot.
>> Why Yeah, why why would you call me a
bot? You want to know why I called you a
bot, bro? You You don't know why? Yeah,
I don't. Am I You going You going to
have to watch the clip back, man. You
going to have to watch the clip back.
It's on YouTube. Watch the clip back and
and and and watch this conversation and
see if you sound robotic. Okay. Okay.
Okay. And that was my point. I would
just wanted to people to go and check
wherever, just not from someone who is
not even a Muslim about information
related to Quran and what is Quran
saying. Why? Quran is literally saying
that
that what you are guys saying about that
that he has a son
the heaven almost collapses how huge
that scene is. And you still What is
that What does that have to do with
Hamza? Hamza, what does that have to do
with what I'm talking about today?
What is your response to what I'm
talking about today, bro? But but to the
it's literally
uh talking about that that we should not
rely on what people wrote
about religion
that uh
So we shouldn't rely on the Quran. Why
don't you rely on Torah then? Why
Christians have you You're wondering why
I'm calling you a bot. Yeah, I'm just
asking you why don't why do you have Was
the Quran written by men, bro? If you
had Torah already. Was the Quran written
by men? Of course it was written by a
man. Everything has explanation how it
happened. But it's not
>> rely on the Quran then or not? Of
written by men
Of it's written by the man but it was
not from man's mind. It was from God
directly.
>> It's God's mind. And according to God's
mind, according to the Quran
the previous scriptures are the
authority over the Quran, right? Of Why
would they be authority over the Quran?
They are just proving that there were
messengers before. Because they came
before the Quran and the Quran claims to
be in line with them and but says that
it's mentioned in them and that
you know, if you have doubts about what
the Quran is saying, you can go check
with the previous scriptures. That's
why. Yeah. Why not? The those all all of
those religions are from God. So that
means that the previous scriptures are
the authority, right? Why would they be
authority? Was
Torah authority over the Bible? The
Torah is in the Bible, bro. Yeah, but is
it authority of what you believe in?
Yes, it's the Bible. The Torah is the
Bible, bro.
So are you Jew Jew or a Christian?
I'm I'm a Christian. Christians believe
in the
>> And what's the difference between
between you two? That's that's
irrelevant.
What's relevant is what I asked you and
how you didn't answer my question. That
definitely relevant. answer to my
question, Hamza?
Yeah, of course. Okay. So according to
your Quran, the previous scriptures are
the authority, right? Where does the the
Quran say that?
10:94 What It says
go to previous scriptures because they
are authority over the Quran?
Basically. Yeah. Yeah. Of course it
yeah.
It it makes no sense to debate with you,
bro. How How you can say that when that
can mean anything beside that is exact
confirm exact like authority.
If you read the whole book
doesn't Just really quick, let me let me
put this thought to you.
Can you hear me? Yeah. Yeah. I can hear
you.
You Okay. What does it mean to doubt
something? Yeah. Other guy other guy
gave you the definition and
>> to you now.
What does it mean to doubt?
>> but what's the point of repeating the
same thing over and over and over?
Hamza
I want to say this right now, brother,
that you don't belong here. Please don't
request back
>> And you definitely know the Quran is the
truth. You're not You're not ready to
debate.
You're not ready to engage.
You are nothing but a bot who cannot
engage. Take care of yourself. Don't
request up again. What's your name, man?
Just call me brother Islam. Brother?
Yeah. Go ahead. Okay. What What's What's
What's on your mind? Yeah, I was
listening to your your debate about the
Quran and about the previous scriptures
and so on. So
>> [snorts]
>> So I have a question. I was listening
and I was listening carefully, yeah. So
my question is when you when you read
the Quran, do you read it in Arabic or
do you read in English? I read it in
English. So do you think that you
You don't You don't read it Arabic,
right? You read the translation, right?
You read the translation, right? Do you
copy? I hear you. I'm I'm hoping that
Okay. I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
waiting for a response.
Why are you waiting for a response to
that question? Because I have a point to
make. That's why. Yeah, but why
Why But why are you asking that
question? You don't think that You don't
think that that question What What What
What's What's the first thing Bro
Brother, what What's the first thing you
asked me? Really quick, what's the first
thing you asked me?
Do you read the translation
>> brother. Stop, brother. What's the
question you asked me? What's the very
first question you asked me? I asked you
you read the translation, right?
>> And And what was my answer? No. No, you
didn't give me an answer. You keep still
asking me question And this right here,
guys, is why I'm from now on from this
point forward after the first guest
when you guys immediately demonstrate
dishonesty and stupidity I'm not doing
it. I'm going to choose me. I'll ask you
again. You're This your last chance.
What was the first question that you
asked me? The first question if I recall
if you don't you remember you don't
remember what I asked you about. Is it
just deflecting well I don't know what
what's your game is. You don't belong
here. You don't belong here. Maybe think
about it and maybe you can come back up,
but you don't belong here.
You just showed me very early that you
don't belong here. You don't belong
here. Next person. Somebody worth my
time, hopefully. Okay. So what What are
your thoughts, man?
Quran is inferior to the Bible. The
Quran is not the authority of the Bible.
Yeah. So I want to ask why like what's
your evidence for that? So yep, chapter
10 verse 94. It says in the Quran that
if you're in doubt about what the Quran
is saying, then go check with the people
who read the scripture before them.
Meaning that You're You're You're What?
I mean to say you are saying you are you
are making a claim like like you are
evidencing it from the Quran or you need
to evidence it from the Bible or what's
your standard that I want to know? Yeah,
my my evidence is coming from a Quran
verse.
I'm saying that the Quran points to the
Bible as being the authority.
No. I I I just want to know the standard
like The Quran. So the Quran as in truth
or as in like what's what's what's your
I'm saying that according to the Quran
the Bible is the authority of truth.
That's what I'm
>> No. I mean Yeah. Yeah. You are going to
the Quran, but you are saying Quran is
inferior to the Bible. So I'm saying
like
I'll say it again and if you can't
engage, brother, I'm going to move on to
someone who can. I just want to know
Here's my argument. The Quran
the Quran's view holds that the Bible is
the authority over the Quran. That the
Quran is inferior to the Bible. That's
based on what the Quran says. Would you
like to engage with that? I would like
to engage, but first I want to know your
Let's get straight into it. So the Quran
says
that if you're in doubt about what the
Quran is saying use the Bible to check
what the Quran is saying.
That's chapter 10 verse 94. Does it say
Bible? It says the previous scriptures,
which is the Bible. The Torah, Psalms,
and Gospel. If If the If the word Bible
throws you off, I'll just use previous
scriptures or Torah, Gospel, Psalms,
writings of the prophets.
No.
Uh it says like refer to the people who
are reading it. It doesn't say Bible.
And where would they be getting their
information from? Whatever they were
reading in the Medina. Which is?
Whatever they were reading in the
Medina. I'll say it again. Which is?
Which is Torah. And? And what? Torah.
The Jews had the Torah. What else? I'm
not sure. Okay. If you're not sure, go
ahead and do some research and check it
out. You don't belong here right now,
man.
Okay. Welcome back. Yo. What's up,
everyone? Welcome back. Welcome back.
Thank you. Okay. So have you been
hearing what we've been running? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So So let me just
clarify your argument, all right? So I
actually know you you just stated your
argument right now, right? I sure did.
So
that's contingent that the scripture
that it's referring to or you're
referring to
is 100% the truth, right? Yes. Okay. So
if the Quran makes a distinguish between
divine revelation and distorted
scripture and it mentions that the
people didn't follow all their
scripture, then this argument collapses,
right?
Nope. Actually makes it worse. How was
that?
Okay. So let me grant you this idea this
this folly
uh that the Quran says that these
scriptures are corrupted
and that people don't follow them
correctly and yada yada yada. So then
this would mean that Allah is sending
Muhammad
to corrupted scripture No, I said divine
scripture.
>> the Quran.
to the divine scripture. So when he's
confirming it, he's confirming the
divine revelation. Okay. So in 10:94,
where is Allah sending him to check the
Quran? To make sure the Quran is right.
Where is Allah telling him to go? To the
people who knew of the scripture and I'm
sure it's it's referring It doesn't say
people who knew of the scripture. It
says people who are reading the
scripture. So people of the scripture.
Right. So people of what scripture? Of
all scripture. Which is? Some are
distorted, some are divine. So this
includes the distorted scriptures? In
this specific verse, no.
Okay. So what scripture then? Divine
scripture like the Injil, the Torah.
Awesome. Okay.
>> So they have the Torah and they have the
the Gospel, the divine scripture
that Muhammad can go and ask them about
and check to make sure the Quran is
right. Yep. Okay.
So according to this, the Torah and
Gospel are intact and preserved. They
have it. They have access to it. And if
the Quran is in line, then the Quran is
good. If the Quran's not in line with
them, then the Quran is false, right?
Specifically for this subject for the
stories of the prophets and everything,
yeah. I mean well not the scripture.
It's talking to the people who know of
the divine scripture. And where would
they be getting their information from?
Only the divine scripture.
Got it. So, if the Quran is not in line
with the Torah and Gospel, then the
Quran will be false in this context,
right? Yeah, but you keep equivocating.
I'm not saying the Torah and the Gospels
referring only to divine scripture. You
read the whole Quran, right? It It
literally says that they forgot a
portion of their scripture, which you
denied. So, what I don't know I don't
see what I mean, you're a smart guy,
bro. 5:14, 5:15. Thanks, AK. You don't
belong here, man.